THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROUGH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO.
SERVAN TEMAS CHAU. CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI. KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN
FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA
CAM LUGGER DOES.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LET MONA.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE THURMOND. TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON
WEBER. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR.
PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR MEMBERS
WE HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESIDENT IN SAM LEE
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVENUE
SHOULD.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
WITH MY DEAR FRIEND AND MENTOR
SOCIAL COURSING WE. RETURNED
JAPAN JUST YESTERDAY.
I'VE BEEN REMINISCING
REMEMBERING IN APPRECIATING OUR
MANY MEETINGS AND CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE LAST FIFTY YEARS.
YES BEEN ONE OF MY CHIU TEACHERS
AND FRIENDS. WHY NO HAS IMPACTED
IN SHAPED MY LIFE?
WITHOUT A SINGLE DISCIPLE HE HAS
MENTORED MANY WITH HIS
UNDENIABLY GENUINE RESPONSES TO
LIFES CHALLENGES.
REFLECTING ON HIS UNASSUMING
NATURE. I WAS REMINDED OF A
QUOTE BY MAHATMA GANDHI WHO
SAID.
A SIGN OF A GOOD LEADER. IS NOT
HOW MANY FOLLOWERS THEY HAVE.
BUT HOW MANY LEADERS THEY
CREATE.
WE EACH HAVE OUR SPECIAL MENTORS
WHOSE FINGERPRINTS WILL REMAIN
FOREVER ON OUR LIVES.
OUR PARENTS NURTURING TEACHERS
AND CARING FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
LATEST REPAY THEM WITH OUR
EFFORTS TO MENTOR OTHERS.
TO BECOME WISE AND COMPASSIONATE
LEADERS TO GUIDE US TOWARDS A
BETTER FUTURE.
NOW MORE THAN WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
RIGHT HERE OF YOUR HEART READY
BEGAN.
STATE.
JUDICIARY POWER.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A FORMER MEMBER
OF THIS HOUSE.
AS WELL AS A FORMER MEMBER OF
THE STATE SENATE. THE HONORABLE
ISIDORE HALL HAS JOINED US ON
THE FLOOR.
TO SEE IF THERE
.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY APRIL TWELFTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE A.
M. ON FULLER FRIEDMAN ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHEAP QUICK  DOT
SYMBOLS IN AT THE DESK. READING
CLICK KATHLEEN AND LUIS READING
THE ROLES CALLED AS A MEMBER
COLOR MOVED A QUORUM CALL THE
ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRY TIME
A FOUR AND.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY THERE ARE NO EXCUSED
ABSENCES TODAY.
MISTER CALDERON WITH YOUR HANDS
FULL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND I'D
HAVE TO.
THE FLOOR TODAY MY GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT MY DAD.
AND IN MY ARMS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BERMAN.
CAMBIADO BONTA AND HOLDEN TO
SPEAK.
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY BELT DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE DID NOTICE. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY NINE BONTA FOR THEIR
MAY NINTH HEARING PENDING RE
REFERRAL FROM THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
ONE OUT TO AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE HOLDEN AND I DON'T WANT
TWENTY AB THIRTY. THIRTY SIX
COOLEY.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT KILEY AND AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY ONE PARKS OVER FROM THE
PROCREATION COMMITTEE IN ORDER
THEM.
THE SECOND READING FILE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO A THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT AND ALLOW THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER SIX.
ON BUDGET PROCESS OVERSIGHT AND
PROGRAM EVALUATION TO HEAR THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ON THURSDAY MAY
THIRD UPON GERMAN OBSESSION.
A. B. SEVENTEEN FORTY DALY AND A
CA TWENTY ONE MS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER OF
MEMBERS WE HAVE.
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT A GLIMPSE BUT
MISTER CALDERON FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION OF YOUR SPECIAL
GAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO.
WELCOME FOR THE FIRST TIME NOT
ONLY IN THE CAPITAL BUT ON TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR MY DAUGHTER
CHARLIE NICOLE CALDERON WHO IS
ELEVEN MONTHS OLD. SHE'S EXCITED
HAVING A GREAT TIME AND SHE'S
ALSO VERY HAPPY TO HAVE HER
BEAUTIFUL MOMMY WITHOUT SHE'S IN
THE BACK IF YOU COULD JUST WAVE
TO EVERYBODY. BUT ANYWAYS I
REALLY LOVE HAVING.
MY FAMILY HERE WITH ME TODAY SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING THEM A
BIG ASSEMBLY WELCOME
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER
FONG FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION
MISTER FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I WITH THIS IN THE GALLERY TODAY
ARE THE RECIPIENTS OF THE ANNUAL
STARS OF LIFE AWARDS PRESENTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION. THE AWARDS ARE
PRESENTED ANNUALLY TO THE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO EXEMPLIFY THE
SPIRIT AND COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING QUALITY. SERVICE IS IN
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE THE
RECIPIENTS ARE FROM EVERY PART
OF OUR STATE INCLUDING MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY. AND GONE ABOVE AND
BEYOND IN THEIR MISSION OF
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
MANY OF THESE RECIPIENTS HAVE
BEEN DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN SAVING LIVES
INCLUDING SOME WHO ARE CRITICAL
IN SAVING LIVES DURING THE
TRAGIC LOSS VEGAS SHOOTING LAST
YEAR.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THIS
YEAR'S RECIPIENTS OF THE ANNUAL
STATE OF LIFE AWARDS.
STARS OF MY VOICE.
AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK
S. GUESS INTRODUCTION.
MEMBERS SPEAKERS I LIKE TO THANK
THE MEMBER FROM FRESNO FOR.
HONORING OUR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STARS OF LIFE AWARD
RECIPIENTS.
AS A FORMER. STARS ALIVE
RECIPIENT I KNOW THE HARD WORK
AND DEDICATION THESE MEN AND
WOMEN DO. EVERY DAY TO TAKE CARE
OF THE PEOPLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU KNOW
WALKING IN THE CAPITAL AND THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR THE HARD WORK
YOU DO AND CONGRATULATIONS ON.
THIS OUTSTANDING AWARD THANK
YOU.
AND MISTER FRAZIER YOUR
RECOGNIZED YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES.
WANT TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM A BAKERSFIELD
RECOGNIZING THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AMBULANCE STARS OF LIFE.
MEDICARE AMBULANCE FROM SOLANO
IS IN THE BUILDING.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE
STELLAR EMPLOYEES GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO ENSURE OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE CARED FOR.
TODAY THEY ARE BEING HONORED FOR
THEIR EXTRAORDINARY CARE OF
PATIENTS IN NEED. THEIR
INTERCALL ROLES DURING.
THE FIRES AND THE COUNTIES AND
THE CALLOUS HOURS.
IN RESPONDING TO EMERGENCIES.
THANK YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART FOR YOUR CARE.
YOUR DEDICATION TO THE PEOPLE WE
ALSO REPRESENT WE APPRECIATE YOU
THANK YOU.
AND MISTER SALAS AS WELL ON THIS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I HAD THE PLEASURE THIS MORNING
ACTUALLY WALK AROUND WITH.
A BUNCH OF OUR FOLKS UP HERE ARE
ARE STARS OF LIFE AND HEARING
THEIR STORIES ANTI GAY ABOUT
THEIR HEROIC ACTIONS THE SAVE.
THE LIVES OF SO MANY IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS SOMETHING THAT
ABSOLUTELY VEHICULAR COMMENDED I
WOULD I RECOMMEND THAT EACH OF
YOU REACH OUT TO YOUR LOCAL
PARAMEDICS REACH OUT YOUR LOCAL
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATIONS. AND TALK
TO THEM AND TALK. THEN AND LEARN
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
DOING EVERY SINGLE DAY TO SAVE
CALIFORNIANS. AND WITH THAT I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE ONE TO SPEND TIME WITH ME
THIS MORNING WE DID A QUICK I
CALL IT MY NICKEL TOUR. UP AT
THROUGH THAT THROUGH THE CAPITAL
NIGHTS ONE IS A WELCOME TO YOUR
STATE CAPITOL IT'S PLEASURE TO
HAVE YOU GUYS THANK EACH AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SAVING LIVES FOR CALIFORNIANS
ARE DOING WHAT YOU DO.
GOD BLESS YOU AND THANK YOU
GUYS
AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRAZIER AND TING FROM MY DESK ON
THE FLOOR FOR A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE BIJAN SIR
TIPPY.
UPON HIS RETIREMENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
COLLEAGUES BICHON SIR TIPPI IN
HIS FAMILY HAD JOINED US IN THE
GALLERY THIS AFTERNOON.
BE DONE MASTERS HE'S ARE EITHER.
WE JUST HER TIPPY HAS FAITHFULLY
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
RETIRING AS THE DIRECTOR OF
DISTRICT FOUR.
WHERE HE HAS SERVED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO?
IN HONOR OF BE JOHNS OUTSTANDING
SERVICE THE ENTIRE BAY AREA
ASSEMBLY CAUCUS.
AS WELL AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE JOIN US IN THIS
RECOGNITION.
WITH AN OPEN OPERATING BUDGET OF
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM OF MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
BICHON SIR TIPPY HAS HELPED TO
GUIDE MANY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE DELIVERY OF THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT PLAN.
THE STATE HIGHWAY OPERATION
PROTECTION PLAN. AS WELL AS
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS BY
THE SALES TAX MEASURES COUNTIES.
AND THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOCUSING ON IMPROVING
PRODUCTIVITY AND EFFICIENCY FOR
GREATER RESULTS.
P. JOHN HAS HAD A GUIDING HAND
IN MANY BIG BIG PROJECTS IN THE
BAY AREA.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER HE
HAS LED NUMEROUS MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
TO IMPROVE MOBILITY THE BAY AREA
SUCH AS HOUSE.
THE CALICUT TUNNEL.
DOUBLE SLIDE.
THE NEW BAY BRIDGE.
AND THAT'S JUST TO MENTION A
FEW.
AS AN ADVOCATE FOR DIVERSITY IN
THE WORKPLACE.
THIS SHOT BEES ON HAS HELPED
INCREASE THE PARTICIPATION OF
SMALL BUSINESSES.
AS WELL AS DIS DISADVANTAGE AND
DISTANT ABLE VETERAN BUSINESSES.
BY INCLUDING THEM IN THE
DISTRICTS COME CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE DISTRICTS
SMALL BUSINESS COUNCIL HE HELPED
ESTABLISH ONE OF THE LARGEST.
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL MENTORING
PROGRAMS FOR ARCHITECTURAL AND
ENGINEERING CONSULTANTS AND
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTORS.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT BE JOHN
SIR TO BE HAS MADE TOWARDS.
PROVIDING A SAFE SUSTAINABLE
INTEGRATED EFFICIENT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE HAS BEEN INVALUABLE.
AND UPON HIS RETIREMENT FROM
CALTRANS HE LEADS A LARGE AND
VALUE TRANSPORTATION LEGACY.
BEYOND.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
EXTENDS OUR DEEP DEEPEST
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
DEDICATION.
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE CONVEY OUR
BEST WISHES FOR A RICH.
REWARDING ACTIVE
AND PRODUCTIVE REQUIREMENTS.
COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING BIJAN
SIR TIPPI ARE ASSEMBLY BEST.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY TO INVITE
THE BAY AREA CAUCUS MEMBERS THE
STAMP ON ADJOURNMENT FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE RESOLUTION
AND PHOTOS WITH THESE ON HIS
FAMILY. AND NOW I BELIEVE MISTER
TEAM WILL LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS.
ON BEHALF OF DIJON.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS.
CHAIR OF OUR BAY AREA CAUCUS
IT'S REALLY AN HONOR FOR ME TO.
RECOGNIZE FEES ARE INSERTED
BEEPER HIS THIRTY SIX YEARS OF
WAR.
I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM.
PART OF MY OF MY COLLEAGUE
FRAZIER WAS A VERY VERY.
DISCOVERED BAY WAS VERY ELOQUENT
IN HIS COMMENTS I JUST OUT A FEW
MORE OF THEIR PROJECTS THAT
DIJON WORKED ON OBVIOUSLY HELP
SHEPHERDING THROUGH THE DOYLE
DRIVE PROJECT WHICH IS VERY
CRITICAL IN MY DISTRICT. AS WELL
AS THE U. S. O. ONE ONE MARINES.
MARIN AND SONOMA NARROWS PROJECT
THE QUIRKINESS OF TOLL BRIDGE
BENICIA MARTINEZ TOLL BRIDGE THE
BAY BRIDGE BIKE PEDESTRIAN
TRAILS AND NUMEROUS MANY OTHERS
I YOUR LEADERSHIP HAS LEFT A
HUGE IMPACT ON OUR NINE COUNTY
BAY AREA.
FOREVER WE ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR
YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE
AND MR MCCARTY.
AND WHEN I RECOGNIZE MR MCCARTY
FROM MISTER CALDERON MOVES
GAS MR MCCARTY YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN CHAMBER.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS
TO A MINIMUM MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE
TODAY AT THE CAPITOL ARE DELTA
DAYS THAT'S WHY WE SEE A SEE A
RED OUTSIDE OF THE STATE CAPITOL
HERE ON THE ON THE. ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND UP IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE THE FAR WEST
REGION OF THE DELTA SIGMA THETA
SORORITY. A PUBLIC SERVICE
SORORITY FOUNDED BY TWENTY TWO
WOMEN AT HOWARD UNIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN. TODAY THERE
ARE OVER ONE THOUSAND CHAPTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
WORLDWIDE.
THEY BRING THEIR ADVOCACY HERE
ONCE A YEAR FOCUSED ON FIVE
ISSUES ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS.
EDUCATIONAL DEVELOPMENTS
INTERNATIONAL AWARENESS
INVOLVEMENTS.
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH. AND
POLITICAL AWARENESS
I PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
WELCOMING THE DISTINGUISHED
LEADERSHIP. OF DELTA SIGMA THETA
SORORITY BUT WE HAVE FOUR
DEBATERS LIKE TO INTRODUCE
KATRINA DONE.
THE SOCIAL ACTION CHAIR THE FAR
WEST REGION REVEREND DOCTOR
GWENDOLYN ELIZABETH BOYD. THE
TWENTY SECOND NATIONAL
PRESIDENT'S.
FRANCIS EBAY FAR WEST REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE AND LYDIA CAN
COREY TEMPLETON ESQUIRE. FAR
WEST REGIONAL DIRECTOR WELCOME
TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
EVER SINCE WE ARE BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
S. UNABLE TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN NOTES YOU TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY THREE TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY ONE
NINETY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE AT THE
MOMENT TONY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY
THIRTY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT
THIRTY OVERNIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
NINETEEN FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOURTH AMENDMENT'S. NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS MADE
TO ELEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE OF THE
MOMENTS. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY FOURTEEN
I WITH AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY NINE
WITH MOMENTS WHEN I PLAY THROUGH
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTY ONE NINETY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S THIRTY TO SIXTY WITH
THE MOMENT. SEVENTEEN NINETY
WITH THE MEMBERS TWENTY NINE
NINETY FOURTH MEMONS TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY THREE NINETY WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY THREE THIRTY
ONE US AMENDMENTS TWENTY SEVEN I
TO WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY ONE
TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY
ONE FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE OF THE
MOMENTS TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY SIX OH
FIVE AT THE MOMENT. TWENTY NINE
SIXTY WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY
THIRTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY BY THIRTY SEVEN AT THE
MOMENTS Y. SIXTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS POINT AND ENOUGH
AMENDMENTS AND TWENTY THREE
TWELVE WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEMS FORTY EIGHT.
THROUGH FIFTY TWO.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEMS FIFTY THREE AND FIFTY
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN OR PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
FIVE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY
SIX.
MEMBERS.
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX AB TWENTY ONE OF THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
THREE BY SOMETHING NUMBER GLORIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
FIREARMS.
MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. A.
MEMBERS IN THIS.
NORMALLY HIGHLY POLARIZED DEBATE
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE I RISE THIS
AFTERNOON TO BRING FORWARD A
BILL WHICH I BELIEVE SHOULD
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ON
THIS FLOOR.
AB TWENTY ONE OH THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH MINIMUM COMMONSENSE
STANDARDS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO LEGALLY CARRY A
LOADED CONCEALED WEAPON.
AB WHAT TWENTY ONE OH THREE
WOULD REQUIRE ALL CONCEALED
WEAPON TRAINING COURSES
REQUIRED BY EXISTING OUGHT TO BE
AT LEAST EIGHT HOURS IN LENGTH.
STATE LAW CURRENTLY. ALLOWS FOR
A MAXIMUM OF SIXTEEN HOURS FOR
THESE TRYING TO TRAINING COURSES
BUT HAS NO MINIMUM.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES CONCEALED
CARRY PERMITS HE'S TO ACTUALLY
DEMONSTRATE PROFICIENCY ON A
FIRING RANGE.
LASTLY THIS BILL REQUIRE
SHERIFFS AND POLICE CHIEFS TO
DEVELOP SPECIFIC LIVEFYRE
PROFICIENCY STANDARDS FOR
CONCEALED WEAPON APPLICANTS.
AND THAT THOSE STANDARDS ARE
BEING TO BE MADE PUBLIC TO
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
IN CRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION. WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH A.
PROFESSIONALS ON BEHALF AYE AND
RELIED HEAVILY ON BEST PRACTICES
THAT HAVE BEEN ADOPTED BY
CONCEALED WEAPON LICENSING
AUTHORITIES.
AB TWENTY ONE A THREE
EFFECTIVELY CODIFIES INDUSTRY
STANDARDS ENSURES ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE CONCEALED
WEAPONS LICENSE ARE ADEQUATELY
TRAINED.
I ASK THAT YOU JOIN WITH ME THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND MOMS DEMAND
ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
COMMONSENSE MEASURE I ASK YOUR
AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER
GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONCE ALL THREE THAT REQUIRES
THERE BE A EIGHT HOUR AT LEAST
EIGHT HOUR TRAINING. IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR A LICENSE TO HAVE A
CONCEALED WEAPON THIS BILL IS A
COMMON SENSE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALL PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALLOWED TO CARRY A FIREARM IN
THE PUBLIC SHOULD. KNOW HOW TO
USE THAT BAR ARM IN A VERY SAFE
MATTER I WANT TO THANK THE I'M
KINDA GENTLEMAN FROM SAN DIEGO
FOR BRINGING FORTH THIS
LEGISLATION AND CERTAINLY WOULD.
ASK MY COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
ZERO THREE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON.
MR SHAMUS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE BECAUSE I THINK.
.
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERSHIP IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
WEAPON YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW IT'S CONDUCTED?
BUT I HAVE A OUT A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR I KNOW READ
YOUR BILL WITH INTEREST AND I
NOTICE THAT THERE'S.
NO PLACE IN HERE. ALLOW ANY
EXCEPTION.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED IN THE
MILITARY CHEN QUALIFIED WITH THE
WEAPON.
AND FOR BACKGROUND INFORMATION
ON THIS.
EVERY YEAR.
EVERY YEAR THAT YOU'RE IN THE
MILITARY YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
SPEND ONE WEEK.
IN PREPARATION.
WE CALL SNAPPING CLEANING
CLASSES EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND THEN THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
MORE THAN A WEEK FORTY HOURS
BECAUSE IT ALWAYS STARTS ABOUT
FOUR O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING. TO
FOR AN EVENING SIXTEEN HUNDRED.
WELL WE ACTUALLY SHOOT LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF ROUNDS BOTH RIFLE
AND PISTOL.
I'VE DONE THAT FOR OF MY THREE
DECADES IN THE MARINE CORPS
QUALIFIED EXPERT AND RIFLE AND
PISTOL.
WITH THIS BILL RECOGNIZE THE
TRAINING THAT I HAVE THAT I
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH SOME
EIGHT HOUR CLASS. BECAUSE I HAVE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF HOURS IN
TRAINING.
DOES THIS BILL BECKETT EXCEPTION
OF FOR THOSE WHO ARE SERVE OUR
COUNTRY.
HAPPY TRY RESPOND MR.
THE SPEAKER I WOULD SAY THAT
CURRENTLY ITS CURRENT FORM IT
DOES NOT.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF THAT ISSUE
HAS BEEN RAISED IT WITH GONE
THROUGH.
TO COMMITTEES OF THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT IT SHOULD NOT
BEEN BROUGHT UP BEFORE.
BUT WE ARE CLEARLY NOT AT THE
FINISH LINE SOME HAPPY TO WORK
WITH MEMBERS MEMBERS TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS OF RIGHT NOW
THERE IS NO MINIMUM REQUIREMENT.
AS YOU RIGHTLY KNOW THOSE WHO
SERVE IN THE ARMED FORCES DO YOU
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TRAINING THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
FOR MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS TO OR
ENOUGH IN OUR COMMUNITY TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND MISTER DALLI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
A.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS THE PRIVILEGE
TO.
.
HOLD ONE OF THESE PERMITS I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
TIME.
I'VE HAD IT FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
DID SIXTEEN HOURS OF TRAINING.
.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO EVERY OTHER
YEAR YOU HAVE TO DO. A REFRESHER
COURSE.
AND I DID THE TRAINING I AM
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORTS IT AND MOST
THE FOLKS TO.
CARRY THESE PERMITS ALREADY.
MEET THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENT OF
THIS BILL. BUT MY QUESTION IS
THAT TIME YOU KNOW I FIND IT
REALLY FASCINATING THAT TO ON
THIS FLOOR WE REGULATELAW
ABIDING CITIZENS THIS BILL IS
BASICALLY. AN ADDITION TO THE
REGULATION THAT WE ALREADY HAVE.
THE BAR SET HIGHER. AND WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF FELONS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO HAVE FIREARMS
THROUGH THE APPS PROGRAM THAT WE
DON'T?
GO DO SOMETHING ABOUT AND THAT'S
THE FRUSTRATING PART OF YESES
SOMEBODY WHO.
MEETS THE LAW AND THEIR
QUIETNESS OF LAWS IS TO SEE
FOLKS BE ABLE TO.
BREAK THE LAW AND NOT US GO
AFTER SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE THIS THIS ASSEMBLY
IN THIS HOUSE AGO AFTER THE
FOLKS WHO ARE BREAKING THE LAWS
AND NOT AFTER AND PERMIT LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS.
ENGLISH DALLY MS MELINDA'S YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU.
I AM EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CALIFORNIA CCW
PERMIT HOLDERS I WOULD SAY
THERE'S NO PROBLEMS. WE HAVEN'T
HAD ANY PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED W. HOLDERS I THINK IT
IS BECAUSE OF THE EXISTING
SYSTEM. WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY
INCIDENTS I'VE HEARD OF HEARING
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S NOT CHANGED
SOMETHING A FORMULA THAT IS
WORKING EXTREMELY WELL.
THOSE ARE THE WORDS OF THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SO.
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS WHO SEEM TO
AGREE WITH ME THAT THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING.
.
SOME OF THE.
MEMBERS OF ALREADY SPOKEN HAVE
BROUGHT ISSUES WITH THIS BILL.
THE FACT THAT IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE TRAINING THAT MILITARY
MEMBERS MAY HAVE HAD.
THE FACT THAT.
COUNTY SHERIFFS ARE REALLY
ALREADY IMPLEMENTING THESE TYPES
OF REQUIREMENTS.
SO IT SEEMS.
I JUST I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
POINT OF THIS BILL BRINKLEY.
DON'T FIX SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
BROKEN.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ALREADY IN
PLACE AND I.
I MYSELF DON'T KNOW OF ANY
PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE HAD WITH CCW
HOLDERS IN THE STATE I KNOW WHAT
THE PROBLEMS WE'VE HAD WITH
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T SUPPOSED TO
HAVE GUNS. LIKE THOSE THAT ARE
ON ON THE APPS DATABASE I KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEMS OF THEM BOYS
CCW HOLDERS.
I'M NOT AWARE OF THEM SO I WOULD
URGE NO VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
ONE THINGS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT RECOGNIZES THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES IN THE BLIND.
OF THIS CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
ISSUE IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE'S DECISION
TO BAN OPEN CARRY.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT PERSONS FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO CARRY A FIREARM IF
YOU BANNED OPEN CARRY.
AND YOU TRY TO MAKE IT AS
DIFFICULT AS POSSIBLE TO HAVE A
CONCEALED WEAPON. THEN YOU'RE
PUTTING PEOPLE IN AN INABILITY
BE ABLE EXERCISE THEIR OWN
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
ONE OF THINGS THAT I DO QUESTION
HERE IS WATER THE COSTS
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE BURDEN TO
BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. IN OUR WE INDEED
SETTING UP A SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE TO HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY A CERTAIN. AMOUNT OF
WEALTH JUST TO SIMPLY EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHT TO BEAR A FIREARM.
MISTER SPEAKER A.
I ASK THIS QUESTION AND I URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY.
MISTER GLORIA YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
ROBUST DEBATE ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AND JUST TO BE RESPONSIVE
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE THIS IS THE
MID POINT IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS OF BUT WE CAN HAVE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL AS THEY
ADDRESS OUR MILITARY VETERANS I
BELIEVE WE TAKEN AT LEAST TWO
VOTES. LIKE THAT ALREADY THE
SESSION WE COULD PROBABLY DO
THAT AGAIN.
I WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN ADDRESSING
ADDITIONAL GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION.
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA OF
INVESTED THAT ABILITY IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US AND YOU CAN
INTRODUCE A BILL IF YOU WANT TO
TAKE THAT ON.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BY SOME WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SUGGEST THAT THIS IS A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM.
AND I REJECT THAT ARGUMENT
FORCEFULLY.
BECAUSE THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION
REALLY ASK WHY CAN'T WE HOW WHY
DO WE WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A
TRAGEDY OF SOME KIND FOR US TO
PUT FORWARD A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT IS REALLY WHAT
THAT ARGUMENT IS. AND I DON'T
THINK WHAT ANY OF US WANT TO SEE
ANOTHER TRAGEDY WE CAN TAKE
ACTION TODAY NOT TO PENALIZE LAW
ABIDING. GUN OWNERS BUT TO
SIMPLY TO ASK THEM TO PROVE
PROFICIENCY THE ABILITY TO%
UTILIZE AND STORE THEIR GUN
SAFELY.
THAT'S NOTHING THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT THERE IS A
MINIMUM STANDARD OF FOR FOLKS TO
FOLLOW ON AND I DON'T SEE THAT
AS BURDENSOME.
IMPORTANTLY THE SHERIFF'S DON'T
SEE THAT AS BURDENSOME WHAT THIS
DOES IS STANDARDIZED ACROSS THIS
GREAT STATE OF OURS WELL WITH
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS BEFORE HE
PERMITTED TO WALK AROUND IN
PUBLIC WITH A LOADED GUN.
AND SO. I THINK THIS IS WHERE
THE LEGISLATION IT'S COMMONSENSE
LEGISLATION JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
ALL OF YOUR OFFICES WERE VISITED
BY CITIZEN VOLUNTEERS OFTEN MANY
OF THEM IN RED SHIRTS MANY OF
THEM OTHER SOME OF THEM FATHERS.
SOME OF THEM SURVIVORS OF GUN
VIOLENCE
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND SO I SAY THIS AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES THAT I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN ESTABLISHING.
SOME MODEST BUT MEANINGFUL GUN
SAFETY LEGISLATION FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO WALK AROUND IN PUBLIC
WITH A LOADED GUN.
LET'S SHOW THOSE VOLUNTEERS WHO
VISIT YOU JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
THAT IN THIS STATE.
THAT IN CALIFORNIA UNLIKE IN
WASHINGTON DC THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS CHALLENGE
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND THAT WE CAN
TAKE ACTION BEFORE OUR TV'S AND
OUR NEW SPEEDS AND OUR SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS ARE FILLED A
STORY OF ANOTHER TRAGEDY.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA AND WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE WRONG.
AND SALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS SEVENTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILEITEMS FIFTY SEVEN OR FIFTY
EIGHT HOUSE RETAIN WHERE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY NINE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN.
THE KERKORIAN AT SOME LITTLE
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME
THE MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
ACTUALLY TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN OF THE CLEAN UP
MEASURE FROM
EIGHT TWENTY SIXTEEN BILL A. B.
EIGHT THIRTEEN. IT WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL COURTS TREAT POST
CONVICTION RELIEF EFFORTS IN A
CONSISTENT MANNER. THIS BILL WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THEIR
OPPOSITION TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE IMAGE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK LOOKING ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTED THIS OUT OF VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLLING TELLING THEM OF.
I FIFTY FIVE.
KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY PASS AND RETAIN
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE THIS IS AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
KERKORIAN WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
REMEMBER GRAY.
MR GRAMM AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS TECHNICAL
ISSUES IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT PRINTED BACK
ON FILE.
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE IS AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COOPERATE
WITH AMENDMENTS
AT SOME LEVEL EIGHTEEN NINETY
TWOWITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
MISTER JONES SAWYER ON THE
AMENDMENTS GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS TODAY I AM TAKING UP A.
B. EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT.
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WOULD
ALIGN STATE AND FEDERAL LAW TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA EXTEND
TRANSITIONAL CAL FIRST BENEFITS
TO FAMILIES LEAVING STATE AND
LOCALLY FUNDED CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS. AND MAKE FURTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT GUIDANCE ISSUED BY
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
RELATED TO HOME INTERNET AND
PHONE SERVICES. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS JONES SAWYER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL'S OUT PRINT
TOBACCO FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER CABALLERO
AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
MS CABALLERO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO BE
SENT. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE.
PATROL ADD MIGRANT STUDENTS TO
EXISTING LAW SO THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE PARTIAL OR FULL CREDIT
FOR WORK COMPLETED IN ANOTHER
SCHOOL BE EXEMPT FROM LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS. THAT ARE
ADDITIONAL TO THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS IF A STUDENT CANNOT
REASONABLY MEET THEM IN TIME FOR
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THESE
RIGHTS TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS IN FOSTER CARE FORMER
JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL STUDENTS
OR CHILDREN OF MILITARY
FAMILIES.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT STUDENT
MOBILITY HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON STUDENT SUCCESS INCLUDING
TEST SCORES RETENTION IN HIGH
SCHOOL COMPLETION.
A BY DEFINITION A STUDENT IS
CONSIDERED MIGRANT IF THEY ARE
THEIR FAMILY MOVE IN ORDER TO
LOOK FOR TEMPERATURES TEMPORARY
OR SEASONAL WORK IN THE AREAS OF
AGRICULTURE OR FISHING FISHING.
AND THESE.
THIS BENEFIT IS EXTENDED TO
OTHERS IT'S LONG OVERDUE FOR
MIGRANT STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COMEY ARABS SEEM
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SEVENTY TWO.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
THE FILE.
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FIVE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY INTO ELECTIONS.
MR LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN MAINTAINS INTEGRITY OF
ELECTORAL PROCESS.
BY LIMITING THE ABILITY OF
SIGNATURE GATHER TO RECEIVE
PAYMENT BY SIGNATURE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS BOUNTY HUNTERS.
THIS PRACTICE THEIR GRADES THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR DIRECT
DEMOCRACY AND THIS STEP PROCESS
BECAUSE THE BEHAVIOR IS BASED ON
THE BOUNTY HUNTERS BOTTOM LINE
AND NOT THE POLICY.
THIS BILL HELPS MAINTAIN THAT
TAKE B. OF THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS AND STILL ALLOWS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO BE PAID. HOURLY
OF OR BY STIPEND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE MISTER
HARPER YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. AYE THIS BILL IN MY
OPINION IS A SALT ON THE
GRASSROOTS PROCESS OF COLLECTING
BALLOT ISSUES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY THE
NONPARTISAN CENTER FOR
GOVERNMENTAL STUDIES NO I
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVES IS WIDELY
EXCLUSIVELY ON VOLUNTEER SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. AND VERY
FEW HAVE USED VOLUNTEERS AT ALL
IT INDICATES THAT THERE'S A
DIFFICULTY IN ORGANIZING TO
STATING A GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT
CAPABLE OF COLLECTING SEVERAL
HUNDRED THOUSAND SIGNATURES.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT INSTEAD
EIGHTY.
EXTENSION OF THE PERIOD OF BE
ABLE TO GATHER SIGNATURES TO A
FULL YEAR WOULD ACTUALLY.
ACCOMPLISH WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO SEE.
WHICH IS RELYING LESS ON THE
PAID SIGNATURE GATHERERS MOURN
GRASSROOTS ACTIVITY AND MORE ON
VOLUNTEERS.
I WE ALREADY HAVE A SYSTEM IN
OUR BALLOT INITIATIVES A WHERE
THEY'RE ONLY BEING I HEARD
DURING GENERAL ELECTIONS EVERY
TWO YEARS AND INSTEAD EXTENDING
THE TIME WOULD BE A MUCH BETTER
REVENUE.
ON THIS I BELIEVE THAT THIS
WOULD LIMIT THE PUBLIC'S.
PARTICIPATION IN THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
WOULD BE INTERESTED OFTEN IN
PROTECTING ITS OWN TURF UP
BECAUSE THE BALLOT ISSUE PROCESS
WAS DESIGNED FOR THE VOTERS ARE
TO BE ABLE TO GO AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE BUT
INSTEAD. WE SHOULD GRANT THAT
OUT WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE
AUTHORITY OF THE VOTERS ON THIS
ISSUE. OF THIS IS GOING TO
INCREASE THE COST FOR INITIATIVE
PARTICIPANTS ARE TRYING TO USE
US SOME SORT OF SALARY.
OR WAGE I EFFORT I IS GOING TO
BE MORE COSTLY INSTEAD OF.
THE PERCH SIGNATURE.
EFFORT OUT WHICH PAYS FOLKS FOR
THE ACTUAL PREDICT PRODUCTIVITY
THAT THE INDEED GIVE AYE TO THE
CAMPAIGN TO QUALIFY SPOT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PREVIOUSLY
VETOED SIMILAR LEGISLATION S. B.
C. ONE SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WAS
CARRIED BY CORPORATE NOT.
TWENTY ELEVENI WOULD HAVE DONE
A VERY SIMILAR THING IN IT WAS
VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN. I
THINK PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE
GOVERNOR'S EVEN REALIZE THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO SQUELCH THE
POWER OF THEIR OWN IN FUTURE
GOVERNOR'S BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE PROCESS. IS
AGAIN AWAY TO GO AROUND THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND GO
DIRECTLY TO THE VOTERS SOMETHING
THAT I'M SURE THAT EVERY
GOVERNOR WOULD ACTUALLY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP. AND I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
POTENTIALLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CALIFORNIA CARTS OF NOTED AYE
THAT THERE ARE THAT THESE ARE
AMONG THE MOST PRECIOUS RIGHTS
OF OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IT IS
THE DUTY THE COURTS.
JEALOUSLY GUARD OF THESE RIGHTS
FROM LEGISLATIVE INTERFERENCE
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT LEGISLATIVE INTERFERENCE
AND OBSTRUCTION TO THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS I WOULD URGE
MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE NO. AND
KEEP THEIR HANDS OFF THE BALLOT
ISSUE PROCESS
GIVEN MORE TIME.
BUT I THINK THIS IS
OBSTRUCTIONIST AND DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD NOT
THROW UP IN FOUGHT AGAINST THE
VOTERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
MR LOW YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER I JUST
WANTED TO REFERENCE THAT THE
STATE OF OREGON HAS PASSED A
SIMILAR LAW. IN WHICH THE COURTS
HAVE A POLL HAVE HELD A THAT
SPECIFIC LAW I'D THAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY FOCUSES ON AT
GETTING RID OF THE INCENTIVIZING
OF SUCH UNETHICAL CONDUCT. AND
FACT I WAS JUST BUST JUST BUT A
FEW MONTHS AGO I WAS.
AT A GROCERY STORE.
NEARBY IN WHICH I SAW PITCH IN
THERE TOGETHER COME TO ME AND
ASKED ME. TO SIGN THIS
PARTICULAR PETITION AND AS I
BEGAN TO ENGAGE IN A THOUGHTFUL
DIALOG INDIVIDUAL THEN QUICKLY
REALIZED THAT IT WAS NOT WORTH
THIS INDIVIDUALS TIME TO TALK TO
ME ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AND MOVED
ON TO THE NEXT PERSON WE DON'T
WANT TO ALLOW THIS PROCESS TO
CONTINUE THIS INDEED THESE
INDIVIDUALS CAN STILL BE PAID.
BY THE HOUR OR BY STIPEND AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RURAL ITALIANIZED FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY FOUR.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
SIXTY FIVE AND SIXTY SIX PASS
AND RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN.
THAT IS A. B. THREE THOUSAND
TWO.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY  TO BUY
SOMETHING ARE GRAYSON AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE DISABILITY
ACCESS.
MISTER GRAYSON EMAIL OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND TWO
WHICH IS A PROACTIVE MEASURE.
THAT PROVIDES HELPFUL RESOURCES
AND INFORMATION TO BUSINESS
OWNERS TO INCREASE THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT WE KNOW IT
IS ADA. AND RELATED LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THAT GUARANTEE EQUAL
ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
TOO OFTEN BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES ARE UNAWARE OF
THE INTRICACIES OF THESE LAWS
WHEN CONSTRUCTING OR MODIFYING
THE PUBLIC FACILITIES.
THE KEY IS GETTING THIS
INFORMATION INTO THEIR HANDS OR
INTO THE HANDS OF BUSINESS
OWNERS EARLY IN THEIR PLANNING
PROCESS BEFORE A SHOVEL IT'S THE
GROUND. THAT IS WHY I HAVE
AUTHORED THIS BILL TO REQUIRE
ANY LOCAL AGENCY THAT ISSUES
BUILDING PERMITS FOR RENOVATION
OR NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. TO
ATTACH AN ADDITIONAL
INFORMATIONAL EIGHTY A NOTICE
DIRECTLY TO THE APPLICATION FOR
A BUILDING PERMIT THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINGS GRAYSON.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK LOVED THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE IN THAILAND I SEVENTY
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN
A FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ITS YOU NINE H. R. NINETY EIGHT.
I MISTER HOLD IN THE CLERK WILL
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY
EIGHT BY SELLING MEMBER HOLDEN
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN OF NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT.
MR HOLDING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
TO PRESENT ACR NINETY A WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN.
LED BY SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE AND DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR THE
POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN BROUGHT
TOGETHER POOR PEOPLE ACROSS THE
NATION TO IMPROVE THE LIVES. OF
ALL AMERICANS AFFECTED BY
POVERTY.
THE POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN MAKE
EXPANDED THE GOALS OF SCLC
BEYOND CIVIL RIGHTS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS
THE CORNERSTONE EVENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN WAS TO BE A NEW MARCH
ON WASHINGTON. ORIGINALLY SET
FOR APRIL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SECOND NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. BUT
WAS POSTPONED BY TO MAY TWELFTH
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AFTER THE
ASSASSINATION OF DR KING.
THE POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN WAS
THE LAST ORGANIZED EFFORT BY DR
KING BEFORE HIS DEATH.
DESPITE THESE EFFORTS THE STATUS
OF POOR PEOPLE HAS NOT CHANGED
FOR THE BETTER AT ALL.
IMPOVERISHED INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FACE DEVASTATING
HOUSING CRISIS.
FOOD DESERT'S BROKEN SCHOOL
SYSTEMS AND JOB INSTABILITY.
AS WE REMEMBER ANOTHER GREAT
WORK OF DOCTOR KING AND THE SCLC
WE MUST REMIND OURSELVES THAT
WE'RE LIVING IN A TIME WHERE THE
AMERICAN DREAM. SEEMS
UNATTAINABLE WERE INCOME
INEQUALITY CONTINUES TO POLARIZE
AND WHERE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
WIDENS.
WE HEAR THAT EDUCATION IS THE
GREAT EQUALIZER. BUT NOT BY
ITSELF.
ACCORDING TO STUDIES BY THE
NATIONAL BUREAU OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH AT UC BERKELEY. DR KING
EMPHASIZED THE NEED FOR POOR
WHITES BLACKS LATINOS ASIANS AND
NATIVE AMERICANS TO UNITE.
HE ASSERTED THAT THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN WOULD ONLY BE
SUCCESSFUL IF THE POOR COULD
COME TOGETHER ACROSS ALL THE
OBSTACLES AND BARRIERS SET UP TO
DIVIDE US.
THE POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN NEW
THAT POVERTY HAS NO RACE.
WE AS LEGISLATORS MUST DO OUR
PART IN ENSURING THAT NO ONE
REMAINS IN THE SHADOWS WORDS
LEFT BEHIND.
AS HUMAN BEINGS THERE MUST BE A
COMMON THREAD OF COMPASSION
AMONG ALL OF US.
AND A DESIRE TO DO MORE FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE LESS.
THE BLACK CAUCUS IS PROUD TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK IT OF GREAT
LEADERS LIKE DOCTOR KING AND
URGE YOU ALL TO FOLLOW IN HIS
FOOTSTEPS TO UNITE AS A HUMAN
RACE. DESPITE PERCEIVED
DIFFERENCES.
OR BARRIERS.
COLLEAGUES I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON HR NINETY EIGHT. AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
FIRST ROW BE OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS AND THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. BE ADDED AS A JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AND IN PARTICULAR.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA.
ABOUT HALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR NINETY
EIGHT. IN COMMEMORATION OF THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN.
IN MAY OF NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
DESCRIBED THE SOCIAL CLIMATE
CHANGE. AS A SHIFT FROM THE ERA
OF CIVIL RIGHTS TO THE ERA OF
HUMAN RIGHTS.
DOCTOR KING'S WORDS AND POWERFUL
IDEAS TO A NOT THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN SERVED AS A BEACON OF
HOPE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SUFFERING.
AND REMAINED AS A MESSAGE OF
UNITY.
HE CALLED FOR MASS ORGANIZATION
AS THE KEY TO EMPOWERMENT CHANGE
AND REFORM.
TODAY FIFTY YEARS SINCE THE
CAMPAIGN BEGAN WE REFLECT UPON
THE CONDITION OF LIFE IN
AMERICA.
AND IN OUR HOME OF CALIFORNIA.
THE API COMMUNITY THE POVERTY
RATE REMAINS A MAJOR CONCERN
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE DIG DEEPER
INTO THE ASIAN NATIVE. NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
SUBGROUPS.
IN CALIFORNIA THE NUMBER OF
API'S LIVING IN POVERTY IS
NEARLY AT FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND. THE NUMBER FOR NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
NEARLY A TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
WE SEE THESE NUMBERS ON THE RISE
CAUSED BY MANY DIFFERENT FACTORS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS A LOT OF HELP ACCESS. BUT
ALSO BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
HONEST DIALOGUE WITH ERIC
COMMUNITIES ABOUT POVERTY.
ON TUESDAY MAY TWENTY FIRST
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. THOUSANDS
OF POOR PEOPLE SET UP A TENT
CITY ON THE CAPITOL MALL FORCING
THOSE IN THE HALLS OF POWER TO
SEE THE FACES OF THE POOR WHO
HAD COME TO LOBBY THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES.
THIS WAS RESURRECTION CITY.
THE CLIMAX OF THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN UP PRESENCE IN OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL A SOLIDARITY
DAY ON JUNE NINETEENTH NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WILL BETWEEN FIFTY
THOUSAND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
PROTESTING RATTLING AND CALLING
ON THEIR LEADERS. IN THE CAPITAL
TO ACTUALLY LISTEN TO THEIR
CONCERNS.
THE NEXT DAY BEGAN THE BEGINNING
A FORCEFUL POLICE ACTION TO
DISBAND THE CAMP.
AS WE LOOK BACK ON THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE STILL LIVE IN A SOCIETY
WHERE MILLIONS OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS UNDER RESOURCED. AND
THAT ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
INEQUITY STILL EXIST.
AS WE REFLECT ON RESURRECTION
CITY LET US RESURRECT OUR FIGHT.
FOR ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
WE MUST CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
ACT EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AND REMEMBER
THAT THE UNDERLYING CORE. OF THE
POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN WAS AN
ECONOMIC BILL OF RIGHTS WITH
VERY SPECIFIC BUDGET AND POLICY
DEMANDS A CONGRESS INCLUDING A
THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR ANTI
POVERTY PACKAGE AS WE GO THROUGH
BILLS AND BUDGET THIS YEAR. LET
US REMEMBER THE POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I DON'T THINK MEMBER FROM
PASADENA.
THERE IS KALRA MISTER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR NINETY EIGHT I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
AND HIS AUTHORSHIP AND BRING IT
FORWARD ARM AND SIMPLY ADD I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS.
AND HAPPY TO ADD MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RECOGNITION OF
FIFTY YEARS SINCE THE POOR
PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN.
ARE SADLY THOUGH. IN FIFTY
YEARS.
VERY LITTLE HAS CHANGED
MANY CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
LIVE. IN POVERTY IN DEEP POVERTY
A FOURTEEN POINT THREE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE BASIC A. BASIC EIGHT IS
CONSIDERED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR.
OUR CHILDREN ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY AT A RATE OF TWENTY ONE.
POINT SIX
SAN.
THIRTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE EITHER POOR
OR NEAR POOR CONDITIONS.
AND EVEN WITH SOME OF THE SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS THAT HELP TO KEEP
EIGHT POINT TWO PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S OUT OF POVERTY
PROGRAMS LIKE CAL FRESH. CAO
WORKS IN THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WHICH IS VERY BODY HELP
TO CREATE.
WE STILL SEE THAT SEVENTY NINE
POINT FOUR PERCENT OF THE POOR
HAVE AT LEAST ONE WORKING ADULTS
IN THE FAMILY IN MANY CASES
SOMEONE WHO'S WORKING FULL TIME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
ETHNIC BREAKDOWNS FOR POVERTY
LATINOS REPRESENT TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF THOSE LIVING IN
POVERTY SEVENTEEN POINT ONE
PERCENT FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
SEVENTEEN PERCENT FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS. THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
PERCENT FOR WHITES.
WE KNOW THAT DO EDUCATION AND
JOB CREATION AND JOB STIMULATION
WE CAN HELP THOSE TO BE OUT OF
POVERTY AND A BIT PROVIDE MORE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. THERE ARE
PROJECTIONS AT ALL BE A MILLION
AND A HALF JOBS IN TECHNOLOGY IN
JUST A FEW YEARS BUT ONLY HALF
THE APPLICANTS FOR THOSE JOBS.
WHY NOT INVEST ONE NOT CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE TO GET
MORE EDUCATION MORE TRAINING TO
GO TO WORK IN THOSE JOBS AND
EARN A DECENT WAY TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES? AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES
POVERTY IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CHANGE IN OUR LIFETIME LET'S
MAKE TODAY MORE THAN JUST
SUPPORTING A RESOLUTION I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR NINETY
EIGHT.
MEMES THURMAN.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS.
SEEKING RECOGNITION.
STIR HOLDING YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
BUT HE WAS SPEAKER I WILL LET.
MY COLLEAGUES FROM BERKELEY AND
SAN JOSE.
I I ASSOCIATE WITH MYSELF WITH
THEIR COMMENTS AND I'LL LET THAT
BE MY CLOTHES.
IN IS HOLDING YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR NINETY
EIGHT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE A ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY EIGHT
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
EIGHT BY SEVEN NUMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACTUALLY THE TRANSPORTATION.
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
EIGHT AUTHORIZES LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO ADOPT A COMMUTER
BENEFITS ORDINANCE TO EXPAND ITS
EXISTING VEHICLE TRIP REDUCTION
PROGRAMS.
A STUDY THAT WAS RELEASED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH
SURPRISE ABSOLUTELY NO ONE
CONCLUDED THAT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS HOME TO THE WORST
CONGESTION IN THE WORLD. LA
COMMUTERS SPEND OVER ONE HUNDRED
HOURS DURING.
PEAK TIMES STUCK IN TRAFFIC.
THE GOAL OF THE COMMUTER
BENEFITS PROGRAM FOR LA COUNTY
WOULD BE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND INCREASE RENTS A
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP.
AB TWENTY FIVE A SPORTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY LA METRO MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI. LA BIZ FED ON THE
AUTOMATED TRANSIT UNION LOCAL.
TWELVE SEVENTY SEVEN IT IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS FRIEDMAN SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL UP THE ROAD. MEMBERS
VOTE.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL ANTI THE VOTE EYES
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
SEVENTY ONE AND SEVENTY TWO.
PASS RETAIN WERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE BY SELLING MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND ACTUALLY THE
FISHING. IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
REMAIN OPEN THANK YOU AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY NINE WOULD CRACKDOWN
ON POACHING BY COMMERCIAL
ENTITIES AND OUR MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS.
CURRENTLY THE LOW PENALTIES FOR
POACHING MAKE IT FAR TOO EASY
FOR BAD ACTORS TO ABSORB THE
FINES AS A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS.
THIS THREATENS NOT ONLY OUR
EFFORTS TO CONSERVE AND PROTECT
MARINE LIFE AND HABITAT BUT ALSO
HURTS BUSINESSES WHICH STRIVE TO
TO RESPECT AND FOLLOW OUR LAWS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY NINE WOULD
INCREASE THE PENALTIES FOR
COMMERCIAL ENTITY WHICH POACHERS
IN AN MPA IN ORDER PROVIDE AN
EFFECTIVE DETERRENT.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ENSURE THAT
THESE HIGHER PENALTIES WILL FALL
ON THE PARTY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ACTUAL VIOLATION. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE VOTE.
THAT THEY IN HIS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER MISTER HARPER YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
AMENDMENTS IN I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND I THINK IT'S GREAT
TO SEE A COUPLE OF BILLS TODAY.
OTHER BEING SUPPORTED BY THE
MAJORITY THAT EITHER ESTABLISH
NEW OR INCREASED PENALTIES.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WE ARE CLOSE.
RECENTLY ASKED AND I HAVE.
CLERK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
USE THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY VOTES.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ADAM
SEVENTY FOUR AND SEVENTY FIVE
PASSED TO RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX A.
B.?
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER THURMOND
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE WAS IN AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR. IN JUST
A MOMENT AGO WE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUING THE
EFFORTS OF THE CAMPAIGN TO END
POVERTY. UP THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT HELP ON MANY
INDIVIDUAL STAY OUT OF POVERTY
ARE WILL. ARE MAINTAINED AND
WILL DELIVER TO SHIFT
SPECIFICALLY PROGRAMS LIKE
HEALTH FRESH.
CAL WORKS.
AND MEDI CAL.
THIS BILL SAYS THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS SHOULD BE I CARRIED OUT
BY MARRIAGE OR CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES AS OPPOSED TO. BY FOR
PROFIT. COMPANIES
UP THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR COUNTY.
PRIVATIZE ELIGIBILITY WORKFORCE
WITH THE WAIVER APPROVAL. THIS
SETS UP A RISK WHERE AN ACTOR
WHO IS CARRYING OUT THESE
PROGRAMS COULD BE PUTTING THE
PROFIT MOTIVE ONE INCENTIVES
AHEAD OF WHAT IS BEST FOR THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AS WELL AS
RECOGNIZING THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
MERIT EMPLOYEES.
PROVIDING THE PROGRAM THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WHISTLE
BLOWING TO REPORT WHEN THERE ARE
IRREGULARITIES ARE PROBLEMS AND
HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE BEING
CONDUCTED. ON BEHALF OF THE
RECIPIENTS OF THESE PROGRAMS WHO
REALLY NEED THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY THREE TO
TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MS THURMAN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CARPOOL UP THE ROAD.
VOTERS ARAB ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN MAY BE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY MR
MEDINA CLERK WILL READ.
S. UNABLE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOME A MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION GOVERNANCE MR MEDINA
EMAIL BUT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG.
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATING ALL OF ITS STUDENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN.
CLARIFIES AND.
.
IT MAKES INTO.
IT'S A STATUE.
THAT ALL STUDENTS DESPITE.
THERE DOCUMENTATION. AND
DOCUMENTATION.
CONSERVE ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS
PERTAINING TO EDUCATION.
OF THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AMOS MEDINA SCENE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF
ANTI SIXTY KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT IS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER WHAT AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
DOCTOR WILLIAM AILMENT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER THIS
BILL REQUIRES APPLICANTS FOR A
SKILLED THERE FOR NURSING
FACILITY OR A SNIFF.
A LICENSE TO DISCLOSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHETHER OR NOT THE APPLICANT OR
THEIR PARTNER HAS A NEW
OWNERSHIP OF OR CONTROLLING AN
OWNERSHIP INTEREST IN OR. A FIVE
PERCENT OR MORE IN A BUSINESS
THAT PROVIDES ANY SERVICE TO THE
SNARE.
SOME SNIFFS CONTRACT OUT BASIC
FUN Y. FUNCTIONS LIKE MANAGEMENT
OR RENT THEIR OWN BUILDING FROM
A SISTER CORPORATION ROBIN
INTEREST IN A COMPANY THAT DOES
THEIR LAUNDRY.
SNIP OWNERS THEN ESTABLISH
HIGHLY FAVORABLE CONTRACTS IN
WHICH THERE NURSING HOMES PAY
FOR MORE MORE FOR SERVICES AND
THEY MIGHT IN A COMPETITIVE
MARKET. THIS ALLOWS THEM TO
SIPHON OFF HIGHER PROFITS WHICH
ARE NOT RECORDED ON THE NURSING
HOMES ACCOUNTS.
MEDICARE PAYS FOR TWO THIRDS OF
ALL NURSING HOME CARE IN THE
STATE. IF A FACILITY INCURRED
EXCESS COSTS BEYOND WHAT IS
EXPECTED IN A COMPETITIVE
MARKET.
IT'S POSSIBLE PORTION COULD BE
REFLECTED IN SNIFF COSTS AND
PASSED ON TO THE STATE THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THIS IT'S
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES ADDED
TRANSPARENCY.
REGARDING SNIFF BUSINESS
PRACTICES AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CAR CLUB THE WRONG.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN
ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WHILE ITEMS SEVENTY NINE AND
EIGHTY PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FOUR CLERK
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
MR JOB YOU MAIL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SO AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FOUR
WOULD AMEND THE PUBLIC CONTRACT
CODE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
STANDARDS USED BY STATE AGENCIES
TO PROCURE NON IT CONTRACTS ALSO
APPLY TO IT CONTRACTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WITH THE GS HAS GENERAL STATE
CONTRACTING AUTHORITY FOR GOODS
AND SERVICES.
IT PROHIBITS AGENCIES TO ENTER
INTO LARGE SCALE NON IT
CONTRACTS WITH VENDORS WHO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
IN THEIR PROMOTE PROVISION OF
BENEFITS ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
AGENDA DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP
STATUS WILL VENDORS WHO HAVE
LARGE TAX DELINQUENCIES AMONG
OTHERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OCD
T. SERIOUS THE AUTHORITY WITH
THE GS FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF IT
GOODS AND SERVICES YET THEIR
PROCUREMENTS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
THESE RESTRICTIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE
SURE THE SAME POLICIES ARE
ADHERED TO ACROSS THE BOARD. NOT
JUST IN PRACTICE BUT ALSO AS A
MATTER OF LAW. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRECDT TO COMPLY WITH THE
SAME RESTRICTIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
ABOUT.
NAMES SHALL SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LOVE THERE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF THAT
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE AND HOW I
THAT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE. GREGORY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE BY SONY MEMBER WOULD
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
REQUIRES THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY
ALL MEDICATION PRESCRIBERS AND
DISPENSERS WILL HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO E. PRESCRIBE. IT
FOR THE REQUIRES A BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE E. PRESCRIBING FOR
MOST PRESCRIPTIONS WOULD BE
REQUIRED. THE RATIONALE FOR THIS
BILL IS TWO FOLD FIRST E.
PRESCRIBING IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO ADDRESS THE OPIOID CRISIS BY
REDUCING THE AVAILABILITY
OBTAINED THROUGH FRAUDULENT
MEANS.
SECOND E. PRESCRIBING WOULD
REDUCE MEDICATION ERRORS MORE
THAN ONE POINT THREE MILLION
PEOPLE ARE INJURED BY MEDICATION
YOU ERRORS ANNUALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES. AND MOST OF THESE
MISTAKES ARE PREVENTABLE. E.
PRESCRIBING IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN ONE
POINT SIX BILLION PRESCRIPTIONS
WERE ALREADY IT WISHES ISSUED
ELECTRONICALLY IN THE U. S..
AS FAR BACK AS TWO THOUSAND
THREE THE CENTERS FOR MEDICAID
AND MEDICARE. MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES INCLUDED E.
PRESCRIBING IN THE MARKET
MEDICARE MODERNIZATION ACT.
CURRENTLY NINE STATES HAVE
PASSED E. PRESCRIBING LAWS.
AND.
ANOTHER.
.
TEAM TOTAL EARTH I THINK WE ARE
LOOKING AT THIS.
HE PRESCRIBED IS NO LONGER A
FUTURE TECHNOLOGY THAT EXISTS
IT'S READILY AVAILABLE AND IT'S
TIME HAS COME ADOPTION OF
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
HALLMARK. OF THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION ADOPTION OF E.
PRESCRIBING IS NO UPS EXCEPTIONS
THE IMPORTANT ELEMENT PER
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF PATIENT
CARE.
REDUCING PRESCRIPTION FRAUD AND
ULTIMATELY SAVING LIVES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY ELECT WOULDN'T SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
THOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THREE THROUGH
EIGHTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
ON THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
THIS IS E. BE ARMY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN
S. C. R. EIGHTY EIGHT.
CORKERY.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WHEN AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH.
SURE KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SO IT'S A GREAT HONOR. TO BE
ABLE TO BRING TO THE FLOOR SCR
EIGHTY EIGHT.
DECLINE THE MONTH OF APRIL AS
BLACK APRIL MONTH.
TODAY APRIL THIRTIETH MARKS THE
FORTY THIRD ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FALL OF SAIGON THE COMMUNIST
TAKEOVER OF SOUTH VIETNAM AND
THE END OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
THIS LOSS OF THE VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE MILITARY ALLIES INCLUDING
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
RESULTED IN AN INTERNET O.
INTERCONTINENTAL EXODUS FOR
MILLIONS OF VIETNAMESE PEOPLE BY
LAND AIR AND SEA.
THOSE WHO ESCAPE BY HELICOPTER
WILL BE PART OF THE LARGEST
EMERGENCY HELICOPTER EVACUATION
IN HISTORY.
THOSE WHO FLED BY BOAT.
BUT BASS BLEAK OSSIFIED WEEKS AT
SEA AND PILLAGING BY PIRATES FOR
A CHANCE TO FIND SAFETY.
FROM PERSECUTION.
AS WE HAVE REFLECT UPON THE
TRAGIC STRUGGLES WITH THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY HE
OF THAT THE BEANIES AMERICAN
AREA SPACE WE MAKE ME PAY
RESPECTS THE LIES OF A LOST AT
SEA. FAMILIES THAT WERE
SEPARATED DURING THIS TUMULTUOUS
TIME. AND SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS
WHO DIED DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
YET THROUGH THE DETERMINATION
STRENGTH OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY WE ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR THEIR
TREMENDOUS SUCCESSES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THEY HAVE CREATED.
AGAINST FIERCE ODDS.
FOR THE YOUNGER GENERATION OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS.
TODAY CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO MORE
THAN FIVE HUDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND VIETNAMESE PEOPLE MANY
OF WHOM ESCAPE COMMUNIST VIETNAM
IN THE PURSUIT FOR FREEDOM.
DEMOCRACY AND A BETTER FUTURE.
WHAT THE POPULATION OF WELL OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
IS HOME THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF BIN MEANS
AMERICANS ANYONE CITY OUTSIDE OF
VIETNAM?
I AM HUMBLED TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION TO HONOR THE
SACRIFICE IN JOURNEY OF THE
MILLIONS OF VIETNAMESE PEOPLE
AFTER THE PAUSE SAIGON. AND
EXPRESS GRATITUDE FOR THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA.
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
LET US NEVER FORGET THE TRAGIC
TRAGIC LOSS OF LIFE AND
SUFFERING. INDOORS FOR THE CAUSE
OF FREEDOM.
THE VIETNAMESE REFUGEES
FOLLOWING THE END OF THE WAR
SERVE AS A POWERFUL EXAMPLE THE
VALUES OF FREEDOM. AND
DEMOCRACY.
WE MUST TEACH OUR CHILDREN AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS THEIR
STORIES.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
TYPE OF.
THEY WHICH KALRA MISTER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AYE ABLE THIRTIETH ALSO
KNOWN AS BLACK APRIL IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT TO ME AND TO THE
DISTRICT THAT I DO YOU
REPRESENT.
I GREW UP ALL ALONG SIDE OF MANY
OF THE REFUGEES EYE THEY CAME TO
ORANGE COUNTY GROWING UP IN THE
WESTMINSTER HUNTINGTON BEACH
AREA. AYE AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR THOSE WHO BORN VIETNAM WERE
REFUGEES AYE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE AMAZING AND INCREDIBLE.
LIKE APRIL MEANS A LOT OF THINGS
TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
I AYE MYSELF AYE THIS MORNING.
WALKED OVER TO THE CALIFORNIA
VIETNAM VETERANS MEMORIAL.
WHICH IF YOU HAVE NOT VISIT
VISITED IS AN INCREDIBLE MORE
MORAL AND VERY MOVING.
I IT MEANS A LOT I THINK TO ME
ON THIS DAY TO RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICE OF HOW MANY AMERICAN
SOLDIERS. I IN HELMI AMERICAN
FIGHTING MEN AND WOMEN AYE IN
THE ARMY AND MARINE CORPS AYE
AIRFORCE AYE AND NAVY ARE
PARTICIPATED. IN THIS CONFLICT
INCLUDINGMY FATHER IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
I I THINK THIS ALSO MEANS A LOT
AYE TO. FOR THOSE WHO FOUGHT IN
THE CONFLICT.
AGAINST THE COMMUNISTS.
ON BEHALF OF VIETNAM THOSE WERE
VIETNAM CITIZENS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO HAVE COME HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES
I AND I THINK IT ALSO MEANS A
LOT IN TERMS OF RECOGNIZING THE
REFUGEES STRUGGLE. OUR FOR THOSE
WHO CAME HERE TO THE U. S. AND
TO MANY OTHER COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD AFTER THE CONFLICT.
A FEW THINGS ARE WORSE I'D BEEN
BEING THAN HAVING YOUR OWN
COUNTRY I'VE BASICALLY STOLEN
FROM YOU AND THAT'S WHAT INDEED
HAPPENED DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AYE AND IT.
THIS IS A MEMORIAL THIS AS A
REMEMBRANCE.
THIS AS AN OBSERVANCE AYE IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ONE FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS AND AGAIN I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR.
THANK YOU MISS HARBORMASTER
CHIU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MS THROUGH OTHERS
SPEAKERS THEY MEMBERS. ON BEHALF
OF A CLOSE TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS IN MY
DISTRICT.
SO JOSE AND MILPITAS I RISE TO
US SUPPORT SCR EIGHTY EIGHT.
AND THANK THE OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SHALL TAPE FOR A OF
BRINGING THIS ONE UP AND
SENATOR.
A WIN FOR AUTHORED DOES A DOES
THAT SCR. ON UNLESS I KNOW I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE FOR HIS
BEAUTIFUL OF TIE DYE
REPRESENTED.
THE FREEDOM FLAG OF DOPE WE WHEN
WE WERE IN SAN JOSE CITY COUNCIL
WE RACE AFLAC IT IN THE CITY
HALL EVERY YEAR DOING THIS AT A
TIME OF THE YEAR. AND DOESN'T IT
IN THIS SHOULD REALLY A DAY TO
REMEMBER WHO DIE IN THE VIETNAM
WAR. FIGHTING FOR DEMOCRACY
HUMAN RIGHTS AND FREEDOM PAUL.
AND FOR ME TODAY IS ALSO A DAY
TO.
APPRECIATE THE CONTRIBUTION
AALTO'S DRUG VIETNAMESE REFUGEES
HAVE MADE TO THE COMMUNITY.
BY COMMUNITIES AND SWELLED
CALIFORNIA AND AND THE WORD THEY
CALL HOME. AND TO REMIND
EVERYONE OF THE VALUE OF ALL
REFUGEES SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHU AND MISTER
PATTERSON YOUR REGULAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OUT.
I RISE WITH A VERY VERY A FULL
HEART.
.
SHARON I ARE THE RECIPIENTS OF.
HOW WONDERFUL GIFT FROM VIETNAM
ON THAT?
VERY DIFFICULT DAY.
ALTHOUGH THE SON BJ OF ADOPTED
DE SHORTLY AFTER THE FALL.
NOT A VIETNAM.
HE WAS PICKED UP.
BESIDE THE ROAD.
BY THREE GI'S AND.
TENDERLY CARRIED.
TO A CATHOLIC ORPHANAGE.
REMEMBER THAT WAS THE TIME WHEN
PRESIDENT FORD.
SANTA C. FIVE DAYS.
THE SAIGON PICKED UP THREE
THOUSAND.
OF THESE KIDS.
AND TO SHARE AND I WERE A BLAST
TO BE ONE I INTO OUR HOME.
.
AND SO ALTHOUGH THIS IS A BLACK
REMEMBRANCE.
FOR BJ AND FOR US AND FOR THE
PATTERSON FAMILY IT'S ACTUALLY A
BITTER SWEET.
REMEMBRANCE.
A DJ HAS GROWN TO BE.
A WONDERFUL YOUNG MAN.
ABOUT ONE OF MY OUT HARSHEST
CRITICS APPEAR.
HE'LL CALL ME REPEATEDLY AND SAY
DAD WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO ME UP
THERE.
HE IS A PLUMBING CONTRACTOR AND
HEAT HE TELLS ME THIS.
DATA SOMEBODY NOT PICK ME UP ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD THEY NOT
TAKEN TO THAT ORPHANAGE. HAD
THOUGH IT HAD THAT AIR AIRPLANE
NOT COME AND GOT ME HAD THERE
NOT BEEN DIVIDE DISORGANIZATION
IN THE PRESIDIO. WHEN HE LANDED.
I'M HE HE SAYS DAD I'D I'D BE IN
A COMMUNIST COUNTRY BEHIND A
WATER BUFFALO.
IN A RICE.
PATTY AND I WOULDN'T BE FREE I
WOULDN'T OWN A HOME WHEN HAVE MY
OWN BUSINESS. AND IT WOULDN'T BE
AN AMERICAN.
THOMPSON THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO
FOUGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO RESCUED
AND THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO
CARED FOR THE VICTIMS UNTIL
THERE WAS A TIME TO COME HOME TO
A FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
THERE WAS PATTERSON MISTER ALLEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE IN RECOGNITION OF BLACK
APRIL.
IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO REPRESENT
LITTLE SAIGON THE LARGE
CONCENTRATION OF VIETNAMESE
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY VIETNAM.
AFTER THE FALL OF SAIGON THEY
CAME TO ORANGE COUNTY.
THEY WAS SUPPORT IN LARGE PART
BY JOHN WAYNE WHO HAD A BIG
HEART. FOR THESE POLITICAL
REFUGEES THAT WERE FLEEING THE
OPPRESSION OF COMMUNISM.
THEY CAME TO WESTMINSTER
CALIFORNIA TO GARDEN GROVE.
DEVELOP VALLEY.
BULLS AVENUE IS WORLD KNOWN
WORLD RENOWNED AS THE HEART OF
LITTLE SAIGON IT THE HEART OF MY
DISTRICT.
I WILL TELL YOU NOW THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS SETTLED IN
ORANGE COUNTY OR SOME OF THE
MOST INDUSTRIOUS. AMERICAN
PATRIOT YOU WILL EVER FIND THEIR
OVER FIVE THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THERE'S A HARD TO
THIS PEOPLE.
THAT IS IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZABLE.
THEY ARE ROCK SOLID
CONSERVATIVES THEY BELIEVE IN
THE PRINCIPLES OF RONALD REAGAN
THEY BELIEVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THEY ALSO BELIEVE IN A FREE
VIETNAM.
WE MUST NEVER REST.
AS LONG AS THE SCOURGE OF
COMMUNISM.
IS STILL ON THE MARCH IN THIS
WORLD WE MUST NEVER REST.
WHILE HUMAN RIGHTS ARE BEING
VIOLATED STILL TO THIS DAY IN
VIETNAM.
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD HAVE
FOUGHT ON.
I WAS BARELY EVEN BORN WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. MY
FATHER SERVE MY GRANDFATHER
CERTAIN HIS FATHER SERVED AS
WELL.
WE OWE THE PEOPLE OF VIETNAM.
A DEBT OF GRATITUDE.
IT IS OUR HONOR.
TO WELCOME THEM IS U. S.
CITIZENS AND AS AMERICANS.
BUT LET US NEVER FORGET. THAT
THE TRUE FIGHT RAGES ON UNTIL
VIETNAM IS FREE ONCE AGAIN.
WE WILL NEVER BE COMPLETE.
AS AN AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
THERE WASN'T ALL THIS EVER KNOWS
THIS TO BE TRUE EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT IS IT IS VISIT
LITTLE SAIGON. THAT IS SEEN
THESE GREAT AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE GREAT WORK THAT THEY DO AND
THE WONDERFUL LIVES THEY LIVE.
IN MY DISTRICT IN ORANGE COUNTY
KNOWS THIS TO BE TRUE.
WE MUST NEVER FORGET.
THAT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE UNITED STATES
STANDS FOR TRUTH.
IT STANDS FOR DEMOCRACY AND IT
STANDS FOR GOOD IN THE WORLD.
UNFORTUNATELY IN VIETNAM.
THE BAD GUYS ONE A TEMPORARY
VICTORY.
LET US INSURE THAT VICTORY IS
ONLY TEMPORARY.
LET US ALL LOOK FORWARD TO DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO ENSURE
FREE VIETNAM.
AND BE THANKFUL EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT WE GET TO HOST THESE GREAT
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS.
AS AMERICAN CITIZENS
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION.
CALL REMAIN CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR WENT AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
ALSO FOR SPEAKING. UP IN SUPPORT
OF S. YOU ARE EIGHTY EIGHT AND
AS WE ARE MEMBER OF FORTY THREE
YEARS AGO. AS WE OPEN UP OUR
HEARTS AND WE OPEN UP OUR NATION
TO THOSE REFUGEES THAT US AGAIN
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NOT
FORGET.
THE SAME REFUGEES ARE COMING TO
OUR SHORES WERE THERE FROM
SYRIA.
OVER THERE AT THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN BORDER RIGHT NOW ASKING
FOR HARD TO BE OPEN OUR MINDS TO
BE OPEN AND FOR US TO SHOW THE
SAME LOVE WE SHOWED. TO THOSE
COURAGEOUS REFUGEES THAT CAME
HERE ACROSS THE SEA FORTY THREE
YEARS AGO I HOPE THAT JUST AS WE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION THAT WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. FOR THOSE
SEEKING REFUGE TODAY WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
PRICKLE AUTHORS.
CALLERS ASKED IN THE FIRST ROLE
BE FOR CO AUTHORS.
COR CLUB. MEMBERS THIS IS CO
AUTHORS.
ADDING ON SCR EIGHTY EIGHT THIS
IS CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THAT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WHO ARE AT CONSENT.
CALENDAR.
PAYING HOMAGE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
MY APOLOGIES THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY EVIDENCE DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT THE
INCLUSION OF A PERSON'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS IN A PUBLIC
COURT RECORD UNLESS THE PARTY
SEEKING ITS INCLUSION OBTAINS A
RULING BY THE PRESIDING JUDGE.
THAT THE EVIDENCE IS RELEVANT.
RECENTLY WE'VE SEEN A MASSIVE
DROP IN CRIMES BEING REPORTED
FROM THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY DUE
TO A FEAR THAT THEIR STATUS WILL
BE REVEALED IN THEY'LL BE
DEPORTED.
WE CANNOT HAVE A SITUATION WHICH
VICTIMS ARE RELUCTANT TO REPORT
CRIMES TESTIFIES WITNESSES OR
PURSUE JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS. THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
TO ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEING.
MISTER ALAN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO YOU.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
ANOTHER BAD BILL BY.
SENATOR WIENER.
ALL THIS IS DESIGNED INTERFERE
WITH ICE AGES THE GOAL HERE IS
CLEAR TO DISSUADE ICE FROM
SEEKING TO REST INDIVIDUALS IN
COURT SETTINGS.
HOWARD THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES NOT
DO THAT.
S. B. SEVENTY FIVE DOES NOTHING
TO ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
UNDERLYING REASONS ICE AGENTS
MAY MAKE AN IMMIGRATION RELATED
ARREST AT A COURTHOUSE.
ICE AGENTS DON'T SIT IN
COURTROOMS WAITING FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO BE IDENTIFIED AS
BEING IN THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
THEY SHOW UP IN THE COURT TO
ARREST A SPECIFIC AND YOU
INDIVIDUAL TARGETED IN ADVANCED.
AS ARTICULATED BY THE U. S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
IN A LETTER TO CALIFORNIA'S
SUPREME COURT CHIEF JUSTICE TANI
KETIL SIX IQ A.
MANY INDIVIDUALS TAKEN TO
BECAUSE THE COURT HOUSE OF
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
BUT I NO LONGER TURNED OVER
FEDERAL AGENTS BY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR COUNTY JAILS.
AS CALIFORNIA'S.
DEMOCRATS UNFORTUNATELY CONTINUE
TO ATTEMPT TO THWART THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO ARREST
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMES IN COUNTY JAILS. ICE
AGENTS ARE BEING FORCED TO MAKE
ARRESTS IN PUBLIC PLACES AND
MUST TAKE SAFETY INTO ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE COURTHOUSE VISITORS ARE
TYPICALLY SCREEN UPON ENTRY TO
SEARCH FOR WEAPONS AND OTHER
CONTRABAND THE SAFETY RISK FOR
THE ARRESTING OFFICERS AND
PERSONS BEING ARRESTED. ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY DECREASED.
WE MUST.
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE IS ABOUT IT ALLOWS
YOU BLANKS THAT.
WHAT'S YOUR POINT OF ORDER.
HOUSE THAT HE SPEAKS TO THE
MERIT OF THIS FILM NOT SURE WHAT
HE'S DISCUSSING BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT THIS BILL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER POINTS WILL
TAKE YOU MISTER AROUND PLEASE
FOCUS ON THE BILL BEFORE THE
BODY. NOT UNFORTUNATELY
ASSEMBLING ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WAS
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO THE BILL SO
YOUR POINT IS NOT WELL TAKEN UP
BY ME. AND AS I HAVE BEEN BEETLE
AS I AS I HAPPEN TO BE AN
ELECTED MEMBER. OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IT STANDS
UP FOR THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIA
THERE IS THIS YOUR AL NINE HOLES
MISTER ALLEN I'VE RULED ON THE
POINT OF ORDER.
PLEASE PROCEED TO CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS DIRECTLY TO THE BILL IN
FRONT OF US.
IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS I HAVE
DONE IN THE PAST I WILL DO IN
THE FUTURE. THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY CURRENT LAW ALREADY
PROHIBITS AND DISCOURAGES THE
INTRODUCTION OF ANY EVIDENCE OR
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT RELEVANT
CASE AND HAD. INCLUDING A
PERSON'S IMMIGRATION STATUS
WITHOUT I WOULD URGE A STRONG NO
VOTE ON SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE LET'S
PROTECT OUR FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES AND LET'S MAKE SURE
WE PROTECT THE RULE OF LAW IN
CALIFORNIA.
MISTER DAVID CHIU YOUR REDNECKS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
MEASURE UNTIL I JUST HEARD THE
MOST RECENT COMMENTS FIRST.
OTHER WAS A REFERENCE TO THE SO
CALLED BAD. BILLS OF ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE I WOULD
ASK ALL OF US TO NOT DISPARAGE
OUR COLLEAGUES. BUT SECONDLY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER A REFERRED
EARLIER TODAY ABOUT BLACK APRIL
IN HIS FAVOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT PROTECTING
ALL OF OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
NOT JUST THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN HIS DISTRICT.
MISTER ALAN STATE YOUR POINT OF
ORDER AYE I DON'T BELIEVE
SLANDERING
MY LOVE FOR EVERY SINGLE
IMMIGRANT WHO'S COME LEGALLY TO
THIS STATE IS CALLED FOR ON THIS
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON. THAT
HAS COME TO OUR STATE LEGALLY
THROUGH THE FRONT DOOR IS AN
AMERICAN VISITOR ALLEN AND WE
SHOULD WISH AROUND ALL.
MR ALLEN YOU NEED TO ISSUE YOUR
POINT OF ORDER IS NOT
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO GIVE A
POLITICAL SPEECH AT THIS TIME
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF ORDER SIR
PETER NO POLITICAL SPEECH WAS
INTENDED NOR WAS ONE GIVEN.
THE WHATEVER POINT ORDERS JUST.
THAT THE SPEAKER STANDING RIGHT
NOW SEEM TO INDICATE THAT I WORK
FOR FOR ONE ETHNICITY OVER
ANOTHER THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE
I I DON'T I DON'T SEE ANY
DIFFERENCE AT ALL MISTER ALLEN
GET THIS YEAR ROUND CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
THAT AND THERE'S ORDER DOES NOT
WELL TAKEN I THINK THAT MIS
REPRESENT MISS REPRESENTS ME
CHOOSE COMMENTS MISTER CHIU YOU
MAY PROCEED ON THE ITEM THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SINCE THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ELECTION WE
HAVE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT DROP. IN
CRIMES THAT ARE BEING REPORTED
BY OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
AROUND OUR COUNTRY AND IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED OUR COURTS TO
BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRANT STATUS. WE CAN HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE VICTIMS WHO
HAPPEN TO BE OF IMMIGRANT
BACKGROUNDS ARE RELUCTANT TO
REPORT CRIMES TESTIFIES
WITNESSES OR PURSUE JUSTICE IN
OUR CALIFORNIA COURTS.
EVERY YEAR WE LISTEN TO THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF OUR SUPREME
COURT COME TO TELL US ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT ARE IMPACTING US. IN
OUR COURT SYSTEM IN MARCH OF
LAST YEAR'S SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE A ARTS SPRING COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE SENT A LETTER TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
EXPRESSING CONCERNS OF REPORTS.
ABOUT ICE AGENTS STOCKING AND
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN OUR
CALIFORNIA COURTHOUSES
AND IF I MAY.
IF I MAY UP PARAPHRASE SHE
REFERRED TO THE FACT THAT OUR
COURTHOUSES SERVE A VITAL FORM
FOR ENSURING ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AND PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THIS BILLS ABOUT ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE TRUE JUSTICE FOR ALL IN
OUR COURTHOUSES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR
THIS. BILL AND FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ISSUE.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
MIKLOS.
JUST TO BE CLEAR WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON HERE IF ANY OF US.
WHERE OUR CHILDREN WERE THE
VICTIMS OF A CRIME? I THINK ALL
OF US WOULD WANT ANY WITNESS TO
COME TESTIFY WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HIS OR HER
IMMIGRATION STATUS WOULD BE USED
IN OPEN COURT AGAINST HIM OR
HER.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT ICE AGENTS IT'S
NOT ABOUT.
CAMPAIGN SPEECHES THIS IS SIMPLY
ENSURING THAT OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
WORKS IN A WAY THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY I RESPECTFULLY. ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME IN CALIFORNIA ASKS FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT CLERK
LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE ON
THE URGENCY.
EYES SIXTY SEVEN.
KNOWS ONE ON THE MEASURE.
THE BILL PASSES.
NOW WHERE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EXEC COUNTER
I SOME LEGAL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR BY SOMETHING MEMBER BONTA
AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION.
QUIRK OF THE WRONG. CALDERON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RUNS HIGH THAT I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
FIFTY BY SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY EIGHT I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY I'D ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
TAKE ANY CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR.
REMOVE THE CONVERSATIONS FROM
THE FLOOR.
MISTER BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES TODAY ARE RISE TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF MY FRIEND
HARVEST LOSS WHO PASSED AWAY
UNEXPECTEDLY ON APRIL THIRD TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY FOUR.
HARPER WAS BORN IN NEW YORK AND
WOULD MEET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
ANDREA. THE SUMMER BEFORE
COLLEGE WHILE THEY WORK AT THE
SAME SUMMER CAMP IN MAINE.
HER HE GRADUATED FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF ROCHESTER IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND A WEEK
LATER HE AND ANDREA WERE
MARRIED.
THE FAMILY SETTLED IN PALO ALTO
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WHERE
HARVEY TRANSITIONED INTO A
CAREER FINANCE.
FOR THIRTY YEARS HE SERVED IN
SENIOR LEVEL FINANCIAL AND
OPERATING POSITIONS.
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES AND PROVIDE
AND PROFESSIONAL SERVICE FIRMS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY HARVEY BEGAN TO
VOLUNTEER WITH A PASSION.
HE BECAME VERY INVOLVED THE
CONGREGATION BETH ON THE LOS
ALTOS HILLS. CREATING THEIR
FIRST SOCIAL ACTION COMMITTEE
AND EVENTUALLY SERVING AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CONGREGATION.
HE LATER SERVED AS PRESIDENT FOR
JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES AND FOR RHODA GOLDMAN
PLAZA IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
ASSISTED LIVING AND MEMORY CARE
COMMUNITY.
HARVEY WE'RE GOING TO SERVICE
INTERMIX THAT CAN OF DIRECTOR
FOR REBUILDING TOGETHER
PENINSULA THE PALO ALTO ARTS
CENTER FOUNDATION AND JW HOUSE.
HOSPITALITY HOUSE ON THE KAISER
CAMPUS
IN SANTA CLARA.
HARVEY WAS PRESIDENT OF EICHLER
SWIM AND TENNIS CLUB AND ALSO
VOLUNTEERED WERE SENIOR HOUSING
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
HARVEY'S PASSIN HAS BEEN TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL EDUCATION TO ALL
CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE YEARS OLD
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HE COORDINATED HUNDREDS OF
VOLUNTEERS FROM CONGREGATION
BETH ON AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
IN PARTICULAR THROUGH BETH ARMS
EQUAL START EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
THE BILL RELATIONSHIPS WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE ELECTED
OFFICIALS INCLUDING MANY IN THIS
CHAMBER THROUGH LOBBYING TRIPS
TO SACRAMENTO.
IT WAS HARD HIS PASSION FOR
CHILDREN IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION THAT CAUSE US TO MEET.
DURING THE HEIGHT OF MY FIRST
CAMPAIGN A MUTUAL FRIEND PUT US
IN TOUCH.
AFTER LEARNING ABOUT ALL OF
HARVEY'S PROFESSIONAL AND CIVIC
ACCOMPLISHMENTS
I HAVE TO ADMIT I WAS A LITTLE
BIT INTIMIDATED.
BUT ANY EGGS ANXIETY I HAD WAS
GONE WITHIN TWO MINUTES OF
MEETING HARVEY.
WELL AS PASS IN INTELLECT AND
ENERGY WERE UNMATCHED.
HARVEY HAD AN EASYGOING DEMEANOR
THAT YOU COULDN'T HELP BUT BE
DRAWN TO.
I REMEMBER LEAVING THAT CA FIRST
CONVERSATION WITH A WARM FEELING
THINKING TO MYSELF HOW LUCKY
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN WERE DAD HARVEY
ADVOCATING SO PASSIONATELY ON
THEIR BEHALF.
I WILL GOING TO HAVE MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH HARVEY ABOUT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
INCLUDING A MY ANNUAL EDUCATION
TOWN HALL EARLIER THIS YEAR. AND
HARDY RECENTLY GAVE ME A WELL
RESEARCHED AND VERY AMBITIOUS
PROPOSAL.
A FULLY FIND HIGH QUALITY
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA YOUTH.
I WILL DO MY BEST TO CHANNEL
HARVEY'S PASSION INTELLECT AS WE
ADDRESS AS WE ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S.
EARLY EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
NEEDS.
HARVEY SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER
MARTY AND HIS SISTER IN LAW
MADDIE.
CHILDREN JANINE AND LARRY AND
DAUGHTER IN LAW JOANNA. AND IS
GRANDCHILDREN ANDREW RACHEL
KAELIN AARON AND ILANA IN HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY TWO YEARS
ANDREA.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY ARE RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MARTHA LEE
JAMES.
WHO SPENT DECADES SERVING THE
CHILDREN OF OAKLAND?
MARTHA WAS BORN FEBRUARY SECOND
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN IN.
HAZELHURST MISSISSIPPI.
MARTHA PERSEVERE THROUGH POVERTY
AND A TOUGH UPBRINGING UNTIL.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE WHEN SHE
MOVED WEST TO BERKELEY WITH HER
HUSBAND AND LOVE OF HER LIFE
WILLIE JAMES.
BUT SHE NEVER FORGOT THE HARD
LESSONS OF OUR CHILDHOOD AND WAS
ABLE TO GIVE THAT WAS THEM BACK
TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE SHE SERVED.
IN OAKLAND
MARTHA WORKED FOR THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL SYSTEM FOOD
SERVICES ASSOCIATION FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS.
HE STARTED AS A HELPER IN THE
KITCHEN
AT COLE SCHOOL. PROGRESSED TO
MANAGER OF THE CLIMB AS HIGH
SCHOOL CAFETERIA FOR EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND EVENTUALLY BECAME THE
FIRST.
BLACK FIELD MANAGER WITH
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ONE THIRD OF
ALL OF THE OAKLANDPUBLIC SCHOOL
CAFETERIAS.
SHE WAS KNOWN AS MISS JAMES
THE KIDS.
SHE MADE SURE NO ONE WENT HUNGRY
EVEN IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE LUNCH
MONEY.
MARTHA WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR
HER LOVE.
HER GENEROSITY HUMOR. AND COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO LIFE.
MARTHA PASSED AWAY ALMOST ONE
YEAR AGO WITH HER DAUGHTER BY
HER SIDE. AT THE AGE OF ONE
HUNDRED.
MARTHA IS SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTER CASSANDRA JAMES
ELLINGTON.
THREE GRANDCHILDREN EIGHT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
MARTHA LEE JAMES.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA.
MISTER HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE
TODAY.
IN MEMORY OF MARJORIE Y. IT.
NOW STANDING AND LIFELONG
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS IN PASADENA.
WHO'S DEDICATED TO PUBLIC
SERVICE EQUAL ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND ALWAYS STOOD AS A
CHAMPION FOR CHILDREN.
AS A MEMBER OF THE PRESS AND
PRESIDENT OF THE PASSING UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD.
SHE LED THE EFFORT TO INTEGRATED
SCHOOLS AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
DISTRICT FOLLOW THROUGH. ON ITS
DESEGREGATION PLAN.
THE FIRST TO DO SO WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE.
MARGE HAD EXTENSIVE INVOLVEMENT
IN THE COMMUNITY AN OUTSTANDING
RECORD OF CIVIC LEADERSHIP AND
NUMEROUS COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING. FIVE ACRES THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS PASADENA
TOURNAMENT OF ROSES FOUNDATION.
PASADENA EDUCATION FOUNDATION
AND THE PASADENA AND DOUBLE ACP
AMONG MANY OTHERS.
THE INFLUENCE HE HAD ON THE
COMMUNITIES TO SERVE WAS
PROFOUND THAT AWARD WAS NAMED
AFTER HER TO RECOGNIZE.
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND THEIR
COMMITMENT TO CHILDREN AND
YOUTH.
MANY PEOPLE BENEFITTED AND
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
LASTING IMPACT OF HER DEDICATED
WORK.
LAST WEEK I HAD THE HUMBLE HONOR
TO RECEIVE THE MARCH WIDER WORD
DAYS AFTER HER PASSING.
AT NINETY THREE YEARS OLD MARGE
Y. IT LEAVES AN IMPRESSIVE AND
LASTING LEGACY A PRINCIPLED
LEADERSHIP.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO AN INTEGRATED
SOCIETY.
SHE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY THE
LOVE OF HER LIFE JOE Y..
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
MEMBERS ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY.
MAY FIRST CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY.
MAY SECOND CHECK IN SESSION AND
THURSDAY MAY THIRD FLOOR
SESSION.
IT'S AN NINE AM ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AN AREA FOR THE BUSINESS.
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
WE ADJOURN MISTER GIBSON MOVES
AND MISS LIMON SECONDS.
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY THIRTY NINE
AM. AND A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED